- Welcome back, y'all.
We are here with Salma Hayek Pinault.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Her new movie is called
"Magic Mike's Last Dance",
which means right now is a
great time for a dance off.
It's another round of
"Dance Battle Double Down".
(audience cheers)
♪ Dance battle double down ♪
♪ Double down. ♪
(Kelly chuckles)
We need dance partners and a host.
So first, let's get my girl
Jessi over here for Salma.
Give it up for Jessi everybody.
(audience cheers)
- She's gonna be joining the losing team.
Okay, over here.
- What, what, what
- What, what, what, what, what?
- We'll see about that.
- And also joining us is an
Emmy and Kids' Choice nominee.
He's the star of Tyler
Perry's "Young Dylan",
which you can see Thursdays on Nick.
Give it up for my partner and
winner young Dylan Gilmer.
(audience cheers)(bouncy music)
Come on over here.
Okay. So it's lovely to have you
and it's awesome that we're gonna win.
- I'm afraid of him.
- Yeah, I am too.
- Even though he came
out here dancing cooler
than any of us. Yeah. - I am scared.
- So finally, here to
host, you can see him
in the upcoming season
of "Hacks" on HBO Max.
Please welcome Guy Branum.
(audience cheers)(upbeat music)
- Hey.
- Thank you for hosting. Take it away.
- Here's how the game works.
I'm gonna read a question.
The answer to the question
is the name of a dance.
If you know the dance,
jump up on your platform
and shout it out.
Then I will ask both
of you to do the dance.
- Okay.
- Then I will award double the points
to whoever gives the dance
with the most enthusiasm.
- Okay.
- According to my judgment
and my judgment alone.
- Okay.
- Kelly and Salma, you're up first.
- Okay. Okay.
- Come on Salma, you got this.
- You up too.
- Go onto the black part.
- Oh, yeah. I'm not gonna
be hopping in the heels.
- I thought you get up when you know it.
- No, no, you're on the,
no you step on the this
when you know. - Okay,
I got this, I got this.
- If you're visiting Hawaii, you might.
Kelly Clarkson.
- The, the, the hula thingy whatever.
- The hula is the correct answer.
- Yeah, yeah.
(audience cheers)
- There we go, there we go, there we go
- Kelly and Salma
- We need to dance or no?
- Let me see your best hula.
- [Kelly] This is my
hula, this is my hula.
(audience cheers)
- Well, I not gonna go against...
(tropical music)
- The delicacy, the elegance.
- It's like going against
Shakira. I'm not gonna, like what?
- We got one point for Kelly and Dylan.
Two points for Salma and Jessi.
- Absolutely!
- You can do it.
- [Kelly] You're doing it.
- Dylan, Jessi, you guys are up.
- Okay.
- Okay?
- All right.
Jessi and Dylan,
what dance might you find
your furry Easter friend doing
as he jumps around hiding your ex?
Jessi? Jessi do have your answer?
- The bunny hop.
- [Guy] The bunny hop
is the correct answer.
(bell dings) (audience cheers)
That's one point.
- What the hell is a bunny hop?
- Jessi.
- Not real rap.
- Can you do the bunny hop for us Jessi?
- I guess you jump no?
- Music. Please.
(upbeat music)
- Whoa, whoa, okay.
Oo, oo, oo.
- Get it Dylan.
- Ey, ey, ey, ey.
- I'm liking what Dylan is serving.
I'm saying one point for
the question to Jessi,
two points for the performance. - Yes.
- Yes.
- [Guy] All tied up, three points each.
- Also, just once again
I've never heard of what just happened.
So..
- Alright.
- I need this win.
- Okay. Final question.
Salma and Kelly, what dance might you do
if you were a young man short on your?
- Oh, oh.
- Kelly Clarkson.
- YMCA
(upbeat percussion music)
- Ey
- I think that we killed it.
- I get an extra point
because I'm dyslexic.
I'm dyslexic and I spelt it right.
- Did you just say cause
you're dyslexic? (Kelly laughs)
- I'm dyslexic and I get
confused with the legs.
- That's incredible.
- Kelly Clarkson, you do get one point.
- Okay.
- For knowing the answer.
But an Academy Award
nominee just made letters
with her entire body.
That's two points to Jessi and Salma.
- [Kelly] I tried.
(triumphant music)
- You are going up on the
Chicks Wall of Winners.
- Oh, they, they win.
They won?
- They won.
- But guys, whatever the prize is,
can we cut it in two so that
everyone can get something?
(audience cheers)
- I agree. Here's the thing.
I agree with Salma.
I don't agree with the win, but whatever.
- Facts, facts.
- Hard pass on that, yeah.
But everyone's a winner at
the Kelly Clarkson Show.
A celebrity favorite, APL's
women's and men's athletic
footwear sits at the intersection
of luxury and performance.
They're available online and
at their LA flagship store
and APL sneakers come in
striking colors and patterns.
I love them actually,
they're very comfortable.
Congratulations, you are
all getting a 300 dollar
APL gift card.
(audience cheers)
- Go see Salma's new movie,
"Magic Mike's Last Dance".
It's in theaters starting this weekend.